The hawkfish is a brightly colored, orange-spotted
coral reef dwelling fish with an incredible
reproductive talent. Hawkfish may begin their
lives as females, but when there are too many
female hawkfish in their habitat, they have
the ability to turn into males of the same
species. This allows the new male hawkfish
to take on some of the reproductive burden,
allowing the females more mating options. Not
only can the hawkfish change its sex, it can
also change it back! A hawkfish that has turned
male can revert back to female if the population
makeup changes, and more females are needed.
This incredible talent is not limited to hawkfish
either, gender bending is prevalent throughout the
animal kingdom. Frogs, bearded dragons, clownfish,
and many other animals have the ability to
change sex if the situation calls for it.
You might be sitting at home wondering, what’s
with all the animal talk? I came here for an SCP
video, not a biology lesson. Well just trust us,
we’re getting there. While it’s simple for many
other animals, human beings have a great deal
more difficulty changing their sex and gender
characteristics. It can require surgery and years
of hormone replacement therapy to get the kind of
results a clownfish gets overnight. Unless, of
course, a human gets their hands on SCP-113.
SCP-113 is a small, polished red stone resembling
a piece of jasper. When studied closely,
in spite of its resemblance, it was found to
not be jasper or any other identifiable type
of rock. When placed against the flesh
of a living thing with sex chromosomes,
the organisms gender and sex-associated physical
characteristics are changed in some way.
These effects were first tested on humans with
an unnamed D-class. The D-Class was placed in
a sterile examination room and hooked up to
a variety of sensors and equipment designed
to monitor their biological state, health, and
any changes to their body that might take place.
First, the D-class was instructed to open their
hand, and close the stone in their fist. This
contact between their skin and SCP-113 kickstarted
the first stage of the transformation process.
Stage one lasted approximately 0.2 seconds, as
the stone bonded with the cells it was touching,
causing a chemical change and leaving a small
amount of tissue damage comparable to a mild
burn. As soon as this process began, the D-Class
could not remove the stone from their hand.
Unsettled, they attempted to shake the stone
loose from their skin, but to no avail.
It was firmly attached to the skin, and would
not be removed until the process was complete.
The second stage of transformation followed,
lasting approximately 20 seconds. The D-class
reported feeling nauseous, and promptly
vomited onto the floor of the exam room. Next,
they reported a stinging sensation throughout
their body, like being pricked with tiny
needles all over. These sensations have been
attributed to a low-level electromagnetic
wave released by SCP-113 during this phase,
which was picked up by one of the monitors.
After the nausea passed, the scientists observing
the D-Class’s monitors began taking furious notes,
shocked at what was occurring. Though the
modality of it was unclear, the subject’s
cellular makeup was beginning to change. Some
of their cells were registering as nonhuman, and
others were registering as human stem cells. At
this point, the D-class began to scream in agony.
All of the sensory nerves in their body were
stimulated at once, and their brain activity was
overwhelming, at a level similar to a seizure.
Finally, once the screaming stopped and the
D-class had gone still, the rock came loose from
their hand and clattered to the floor. After this,
a full physical was performed, and the D-Class
was determined to have undergone dramatic physical
changes, all of their primary and secondary
sexual characteristics altered permanently.
While SCP-113’s effect on humans with binary
gender identities - male and female - have been
studied, it is still difficult to determine
the sort of impact that the stone might have
on someone with a nonbinary gender identity, or
if the stone in fact takes gender identity into
account at all. There is some evidence that the
stone is impacted by gender identity, though this
is not always consistent. While SCP-113 alters
the physiology of the test subject, it has no
impact on the mind. The subject’s gender identity
remains the same before and after any testing
with the stone. In the case of one intersex
individual who was exposed to the stone,
their secondary and primary sex characteristics
changed to those that would be more affirming
to the individual’s gender identity.
However, as this is still very inconsistent and
unpredictable, not to mention possibly accompanied
by side effects that have not been determined yet,
SCP-113 should not be considered a safe or
viable alternative to gender confirmation surgery
for transgender individuals who might be seeking
it. Further research is required on the subject.
Ordinarily it is standard scientific practice
to test on animals before testing on humans.
However, the SCP Foundation isn’t exactly
known for its standard research practices.
After sufficient human trials had been
conducted, the Foundation researchers studying
SCP-113 decided to test its effects on other,
nonhuman organisms. There was a great deal of
curiosity about how it might impact various
animals, especially those whose sexual dimorphism
or indeed entire relationship to sex and gender
is fundamentally different from that of humans.
With standard cats, rats, and dogs, the impact
was essentially the same as that on humans.
First, the stone binds to the skin. Then, it
emits an electromagnetic wave causing some nausea
and vomiting. Next, the sensory nerves are
stimulated for 20 seconds as the cells become
altered. Finally, the stone falls away from the
skin and the transformation has been completed.
Interesting at first, but after the 20th rat
it starts to become a little mundane. However,
exposure of certain other species to
SCP-113 resulted in some unusual effects.
When a number of Komodo dragons were exposed to
SCP-113, their chromosomes changed from ZW/ZZ
to WW, resulting in the eventual deaths of the
reptiles. When nematodes, which are either male
or hermaphroditic, were exposed, no males were
produced during the experiment. Male nematodes
changed and became hermaphroditic, and the
hermaphroditic specimens were completely
unaffected as far as the researchers could tell.
Earthworms that were exposed to the stone were not
transformed at all, and the transformation process
stopped during stage two every single time.
Several of the previously mentioned
animals were used as test subjects as well,
in order to determine what effect the stone would
have on a creature that already naturally changes
its sex characteristics. Clownfish exposed
to the stone experienced no change to their
sex characteristics, but bizarrely did change
color from white and orange to a vivid blue.
No adverse effects were identified.
Bearded dragons exposed to SCP-113
spontaneously began to lay eggs, which
were immediately retrieved and placed
into incubators for observation. Once
hatched, the eggs contained ordinary baby
bearded dragons that seemed to have no altered
physiology or residual effects from the stone.
The hawkfish exposed to the stone simply
transformed the same way they would in the wild,
from female to male, just at a faster rate
than they would under natural circumstances.
The rest of the animals tested had the same
result as the earthworm. The stone simply
disengaged from the test subject during stage two
of the transformation, as if it was giving up.
As SCP-113 is classified as safe, and only
impacts those who deliberately come into
physical contact with it, its containment
procedures are relatively simple. The stone
is kept in standard storage at Site 23, and may be
handled with laboratory gloves. No living being is
permitted to be exposed to SCP-113 unless it has
been officially approved. If exposed to SCP-113,
personnel must be kept under medical observation
for 7 days in order to study its impact, and make
sure no unexpected adverse effects are present.
After conducting a variety of animal trials, the
research time assigned to SCP-113 became curious
yet again about its impact on human test subjects.
Not on new subjects, but those that had already
been transformed by SCP-113 in one way or another.
They wanted to determine what would happen
to someone who was re-exposed to the stone.
Would it reverse its own effects, essentially
turning them back to the person they were before
the experiment? Would it transform them further?
Would it harm them? In an attempt to find out,
several of the original D-class personnel used in
113’s human trials were brought back for another
round of experimentation, as well as a new D-class
to test the effects of immediate re-exposure.
First, the D-Class who had never been
exposed to SCP-113 had the stone placed
on his bare arm. Immediately, it attached
itself to him and the transformation began.
After the transformation was complete, and
the rock detached from his arm, the attending
scientists waited a duration of 60 seconds before
reattaching it. In order to avoid excessive tissue
damage, the stone was placed on his other arm for
the second trial. Almost immediately, the subject
began to cry out in intense pain, writhing on
the exam table and begging for the stone to be
removed. Of course, at this point it had already
bound to his cells and could not be taken off.
During stage two his liver began to swell and he
began to enter the early phases of kidney failure.
By the time stage four was complete
and the stone could be removed,
the subject had passed out from the pain. An
immediate physical examination determined that
the subject had significant damage to his liver
and kidneys, as well as loss of bone density and
massive tissue damage on the arm where the stone
had been placed. Finally, his genitals appeared
to have completely disappeared, leaving a
smooth surface behind on the pubic area,
like that of a doll. The subject died a few hours
later from organ failure and internal bleeding.
The rest of the D-classes were understandably
reluctant to be re-exposed to the stone,
but unfortunately for them and luckily for the
Foundation, they didn’t have much of a choice.
Security locked the door to the examination
room, and the experimentation proceeded
as planned. Re-exposure after a significant
amount of time had passed had a much higher
success rate than immediate re-exposure, and
the rest of the test subjects survived their
second transformation at the hands of SCP-113.
However, it did not return them to the state they
were in before their first exposure to the stone.
Some of them experienced no physical changes
at all, save for a small amount of tissue
damage where the stone touched their skin.
Others experienced physical changes that had
nothing to do with their sex characteristics.
One subject’s eyes changed color from green to
purple, while another subject suffering from male
pattern baldness emerged from the experiment with
a full head of hair. Some of the changes were more
dramatic. One subject ended up with feathers
sprouting all over the surface of her skin.
Another lost all of his teeth.
One particularly odd test subject
seemed completely ordinary and unchanged, until
his physical examination. During the exam,
it was discovered that all of his internal
organs had changed places inside of his body,
their configuration turned completely upside
down. He seemed otherwise unharmed and
able to function as normal, and still
works at the Foundation to this day.
Even when exposure is spaced out, the more
times a person comes into contact with SCP-113,
the stranger the effects get. The details have
been expunged from the official Foundation file,
but there are rumors that one test subject, after
their fifth exposure to SCP-113, transformed into
something completely inhuman and possibly deadly.
Like I said, the details have been removed from
the file, but word gets around. Especially
words like “claws” and “acid tentacles.”
Those could just be rumors, but who knows?
Biology is full of mysteries, and there is
still so much we do not understand about the
natural world and the ways in which living
things can transform for better or for much worse.
Perhaps some mysteries, especially the mystery of
SCP-113, are better left alone.
Now go check out “SCP-004 - 12
Rusty Keys and the Door” and “SCP-500 -
Panacea” for more unusual object SCP’s!